this is a fox news alert major news in
the race for a coven 19 vaccine drug
giant moderna announcing their vaccine
trials
show that it is nearly 95 percent
effective
joining pfizer as a leader in the push
to end this pandemic
wow that is great news health and human
services secretary alex azar joins us
now with an update
mr secretary this is not totally
surprising we haven't gotten the details
yet
but now we have two vaccines when can
the american people expect to be able to
make that choice which one they want
well thanks to president trump's
operation warp speed that choice is
coming very soon you know this is really
a historic day
this is the vaccine that president trump
partnered with moderna on
january 13th at our nih labs and now
over 90 percent effective vaccine in one
of the largest clinical trials ever so
now we have pfizer
we have moderna and thanks to president
trump's vision we've been making both of
those and four other vaccines a
commercial scale production so
we believe we'll have enough for 20
million americans to get vaccinated
in december okay mr secretary last week
when the pfizer news came out
where it was 95 and 90 effective stock
market went up
uh like a thousand points that day uh
clearly this is probably going to impact
the stock market as well but it's going
to
impact people's lives because people are
looking hey i can either get the one
that's 90
effective or the one that's about 95
effective but the problem
is i've read that the pfizer vaccines
got to be stored at 70 degrees below
zero and a lot of places don't have that
kind of facility
whereas perhaps the moderna is easier
so fast forward to when this is mass
produced will somebody
be able to go to the walgreens and say
give me the pfizer or give me the
moderna
that's a great question and the moderna
one is more flexible it can be kept in
regular freezer
refrigeration so it's going to be
amenable to that program we announced
last week going to your local chain
or community pharmacist and getting
vaccinated the pfizer one's going to be
really good for big
institutional vaccinations say a whole
hospital setting
several nursing homes at once
mr secretary what do you say about
schools because i know that governor
cuomo's even said
if it doesn't get up to three percent
schools can stay open but once it hits
three percent in new york
schools have to close but he said let's
look at each school individually because
some are hot spots and some are not
and i think this is an issue that
americans democrats and republicans
would all say
keep those schools open at least the
majority what do you think
it's ridiculous to close our schools
it's not driven by science and data or
evidence look at the europeans they're
experiencing
45 percent more cases per capita on a
daily basis than the us
they are making it a priority to keep
their schools open
because the schools k-12 universities
these are not
vector major vectors of disease
transmission our workplaces are not
our airlines are not it's indoor
gatherings where we let our guard down
don't wear a mask
don't keep social distance and our
governors keep going at our schools and
our kids
and there's real harm to our kids their
mental health their physical health
their emotional well-being
we shouldn't be closing our schools
right but someone's got to get that
message to governor whitmer
she has closed high schools and colleges
they have to go remote indoor gatherings
limit to 10 outdoor to 25
and it caused dr atlas to come up and
say people should revolt not get violent
but revolt and say this is not
acceptable
they have the strictest lockdown their
numbers are going up like other peoples
are going up
what do you say to dr atlas who said
that to the governor
well i'd say i'd say to everybody uh be
guided by science and data and the data
supports keeping our schools open look
at the europeans like i said
they are about as cautious and as scared
of their shadow as anybody could be
and they're keeping their schools open
because they know schools are safe you
can run them safely
any any institution where you have
leadership following good public health
guidance on how to
keep social distance wear face coverings
we've shown this can be
done very safely and don't these
institutions do not need to be shut down
to keep us safe
right uh mr secretary real quick uh 10
days from today
is thanksgiving you know a lot of
college kids are going to be coming home
i i just read that
boston university is suggesting people
not leave campus they have a friends
giving
other other schools are ending in-person
learning
at the thanksgiving holiday as well
they're just going to go home
but for people whose children are away
for them to come home for a couple of
days what sort of precautions because
you know my wife and i have been talking
about whether or not we see our own kids
over thanksgiving for the last two weeks
well you want to look at what's going on
at that school what kind of case
positivity they're having is there a lot
of infection there at most of our
universities we're not seeing in fact
our universities who have
weekly testing have some of the lowest
case rates of
any places in the country so your kids
may be safer than you are frankly in
getting together but look at those
circumstances
and just use good good common sense look
at coronavirus.gov cdc.gov
for our best advice on how to steer
through thanksgiving and christmas and
what the different mitigation steps are
you can take at home the very common
sense things like
opening the window if you can eating
outdoors if you can minimizing the
number of folks depending on your own
vulnerabilities but
just look at the circumstances and use
common sense all right
thank you okay mr secretary thank you so
much
thank you